Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Ferron cousins. I've been sitting in for
David Pakman and if you want more from me you can
find me on YouTube at YouTube.com. Slash the ring
of fire. I'm also at YouTube.com slash Ferran.
Balanced. Let's get back into more of today's
stories before we wrap up today's show now.
Donald Trump has been out there publicly blaming
Kevin McCarthy, House minority leader, for even
allowing these gosh darn hearings to happen in
the first place. And according to reports coming
out Thursday, it's actually Steve Bannon who has
been whispering in to Trump's fear that Kevin
McCarthy is to blame for all of this. And as
Trump this week has continued to blast McCarthy
in statements and posts on his truth social.
Something rather extraordinary has actually
happened in the House of Representatives on the
Republican side. Suddenly you have all of these
pro-Trump Republicans. That have been coming out
and defending Kevin McCarthy. Now,
before I get into their defenses,
let's just mention real quick. One of Donald
Trump's biggest gripes, of course, is that
Kevin McCarthy allowed this to happen. He doesn't
have any Republicans on the committee. He screwed
up. All of this is a farce and it's all Kevin
McCarthy's fault. So let me read some statements
first on this from Representative
Kelly Armstrong of North Dakota,
who says Kevin made the only decision he could.
What are we going to do? Allow them to just
functionally silence entire constituencies? We
don't get good hands all the time in the minority.
Then Jim Jordan, who of course, has
actually been implicated in the scandal.
Jim Jordan kicked off the committee by Nancy
Pelosi and obviously for very good reason.
Jim Jordan says, let's say Kevin says, I'm going
to give you new names. There would have been
a problem there. I think she was always going to
wind up here because she wanted the partizan show.
Okay. What about Representative Elise Stefanik?
What does she have to say? Well, she says I do
think Kevin has handled this appropriately and
the members support how we've handled this.
Yikes. Now, typically when Donald
Trump comes out and attacks somebody,
the rest of the Republican Party falls in
line and they say, yeah, this guy's terrible.
Yeah, we don't like this woman either. Whoever it
is he's attacking, they're going to go after him.
But when you have people who, of course, are
actually vying for Kevin McCarthy's spot.
As potentially the next speaker of the House,
people like Stefanik, people like Jim Jordan,
who would love nothing more than to be speaker
of the House. They're coming out and defending
him against the attacks being leveled at him
by Donald Trump. That's a problem for Trump.
It absolutely is. Your support among the house
is clearly not as strong as you thought it was.
And that's never a good thing for somebody in
a position like Trump is in to have to find out
the hard way. Now, of course, it could all be for
show. Republicans right now have to basically put
out this united front. They're getting lambasted
by this committee. The whole party looks terrible.
So maybe they're just trying to put on a
brave face and try to stick together as
long as they have to. And then after that,
they're going to eat each other again.
But publicly coming out and refuting.
What your big guy has to say.
It's not a good look, and I don't know
that Trump's going to be happy about it.